As somebody who has done a lot of things in life,
travelled around,
I moved away for college,
I earned a degree,
I worked in news,
I've met a lot of really cool,
famous people.
I have to say that there is nothing more adventurous,
more fulfilling,
more exciting than motherhood.
And I know it's, like,
controversial to say in this day and age.
Like, I'm not supposed to talk about it.
I'm supposed to be like,
you know, it's not that great.
Like, motherhood's not that great.
I'm just tired of having to water it down.
Motherhood is freaking amazing.
And I do think a lot of younger girls,
a lot of younger women
pay attention to the way that we talk about motherhood,
and they notice.
They notice that we complain about motherhood,
they notice that we glorify being a boss babe instead.
And I think we are seeing the effects of that
as we are seeing a decline in birth rates.
And it's just really kind of sad,
I think a lot of women are missing out on something that is really,
really incredible.
There is nothing like it.
Like, it's insane to watch someone come to earth,
like, watch someone be born and start life
and find out what their personality is like,
and to almost have a chance to relive your childhood again
and watch as they learn about life,
it is incredible.
It is so much fun.
And again, like,
I'm someone who Loves to get the most out of life.
Like, I love having new experiences.
There's so many places I still wanna travel.
There's so many people I wanna meet.
There's different organizations I'm involved in
that I wanna continue to be involved in.
There's things I wanna learn.
I love getting the most out of life.
And one of the best ways to get the most out of life is to have kids
and to raise kids.
And to raise them in this world where you get to teach them,
you get to show them,
you get to give them the kind of childhood that you wish you had.
It's incredible.
It's so much fun.